welcome back to the edge with your boy
Michael Parsons live in your Bleacher
Report app I know y'all want to hear
about the Eagles game but I got a
special guest my dog Stefan Gilmore here
with me today I wanted to spice it up
for y'all because obviously it's not our
usual Monday talk so this is going to be
a Friday gym special and my boy Gil is
here with me say what's up Gil what's up
with y'all man appreciate you for having
me bro good it's a pleasure to have you
live over here on the edge man this is
something the spicy something different
I wanted to come outside the box for you
um The Vibes is good everything's great
you know I thought it was a great game a
great robbery game you know between
Eagles Cowboys ferocious you know just
all out the field I think each team
pulled everything they had and I think
it showed where both teams are at I
think the Eagles Cowboys will always be
at the top of their game every time they
face each other but there was things
left out cuse Miss things like that that
dictate the game and then we just didn't
finish the way that we know we could um
Gilly drop drop something that you feel
like uh happened in the game something
that you feel like should have went
differently or cuz we'll get into some
stuff specifically you um but just tell
them something that you feel like they
need to hear uh give them Hope For What
the season continues to be now I think
it was it was like you say it was a um
hardart game from both sides two great
teams playing um could have went both
ways um a lot of ticky Tac stuff was
called during the game um but you know
it goes like that sometimes but um it it
was uh I'm just looking forward to they
supposed to be you know one of the top
teams in the league and I know what we
have left in the tank um I think it's
going to be we have a great year we just
got to keep pushing you know we learn
from that and um I think it's going to
be a fun year for us dope dope for sure
for sure but you know let's get right
into it um thank you for joining what
are the V's been like at practice this
week what the v's been good and here go
a Snapchat of Me versus CD lamb um with
the hands I just want to let y'all know
I have the best hands on the team um
y'all can say it's the bo uh boxing off
season what type of hand you can see CD
stands he wasn't prepared was about to
hit him with this one two right now he
was not prepared Gilly actually been
boxing with us one time and he's never
been back he said it was too much for
him it was too much man it was I went I
went to box with michah one time my
hands was sore for about 2 weeks I said
I need my
hands it might be over for Gilly in his
boxing career but you know the young
Mike Tyson still prevails still prevails
I saw uh Mike Tyson uh training Francis
and I was like man I need Iron Mike to
come train me cuz I think these hate
makers could do something I really do I
really do um but all right let's get
into it I know everyone saw me riding
the tush push and nose is one of them
things that's like when you're not ready
but you this isn't how you planned it or
pictur it in practice right I was I was
supposed to jump up and get the
quarterback but that's obviously not how
this turned out at all so this was a
complete whiff it was supposed to get
stopped and I was supposed to pull him
back when I jumped over the pile so that
was one of the moments I was just
like you know what I'm saying like it's
just what it is um the tou push is still
undefeated only failed a few times but
they are still doing great things with
that thing um biggest takeaways of the
game I would say you know obviously I
think we played a great first half um I
definitely think that the I think one of
the things is we as a defense had to
have a better third quarter I thought
the first fourth quarter we had some
crucial three and outs but I just think
um the refs if you're gonna make calls
you gotta make calls everywhere not pick
and choose when to make calls and when I
say that is if you're going to be pick
uh like picky and Tacky in the back end
you got to do the same energy in the
front end there were some obvious and
blatant blatant like terrible holding
calls that I felt like should have been
called um it it's all been out there but
I think I think at this point we need to
have more refs there needs to be eyes
everywhere cuz obviously these calls are
being missed in the game I don't know if
the ref's eyes are somewhere else where
they're trying it's too much going on
but it needs to be more of something
because these CS is crucial in games
that just can't be missing it's very
obvious so obviously I think there
either be more reps or they just need to
let us play let us play you know um if
they're not blatant calls that need to
be called they need to let us play um
and that's just what it is uh obviously
a hat a he rivalry um I actually
witnessed this Kelsey was laughing
screaming in theone Clark's face like
this was real like I didn't even know
what to say at the time like it was just
one of them things like these dudes are
nuts like the refs were trying to calm
these two down um Kelsey's crazy like he
he's a crazy dude out there on the field
and we just going to put like that um so
it is true uh Dak had a great game and I
think that was obvious there was times
in this game where I was like man Dak
Prescott is dealing right now I mean I
think Dak special I think Dak is
solidifying himself and proving a lot of
people wrong with a lot of people came
into this uh season saying we couldn't
win with Dak and yes we lost but Dak is
putting up numbers that a quarterback
should win with he won almost every
category um there's certain things where
we didn't finish well in and it's a game
of inches a lot of them game uh calls
and you know foot going out of bounds
knee down before the goal line that's
what football is it's a game of interest
it's a game of Pride and Glory and I
hope y'all realize this because things
do not always turn your way you're not
always supposed to win even when you
feel like and I and I you could pervert
this to life you know even when you feel
like you're doing everything right and
you're doing everything in your possible
manner to be good at something and you
expect that outcome and you expect to
see what you're putting in sometimes it
does not pan out and guess what you got
tomorrow you got next week the Prov in
and keep putting at work because
eventually it's going to turn up
eventually you going to gain them inches
you won't come short but you got to keep
being persistent and keep going and now
we're going to get into my Gilly there
was a pass interference call late in the
third that led them to go up that second
possession um Gilly go take us through
your mind here what was going on in the
play um what's your thoughts on this
like I mean I know what I think but
let's get your your point of view so my
point of view was you know he kind of
gave me an inside release I didn't go
for it I kept my leverage stayed outside
I got a great jam on him I stayed top
shoulder and I was
basically I Zone turn it look back at
the quarterback and I basically was you
know on top of him the whole time so I
don't I didn't hold him I didn't impede
his progress I thought it was a good
defense um you know I was kind of upset
with that call because that was a key
you know key uh pitiful point in the
game third quarter um you know we needed
to stop I think would have gave the ball
back to offense you know they would have
big did big things I guess you know as
as a defensive player offense you know
they can push off sometimes and not get
a call but any little thing that we do
you know we got to be perfect you know
so um I guess I got to be perfect next
time yeah I'm I'm going into the gist of
of and I'm always been saying it's a
offensive League you know going with uh
quarterback hits I seen a crazy
quarterback uh roughing roughing pass on
Matt Jones by and ruined KJ Henry's
first sack I mean I've been seeing it
all year of guys pushing guys out to
play weak ring passer calls things
that's not even getting fine but they're
they're calling it out on the field I
mean the pass interferences the pushups
it is blatant um what's your thoughts on
just being an offensive League allowing
these offenses to just put up points not
earning not earning first downs
automatic first downs with these calls
um do you think they should be replayed
do you think they should be challenged
what's your keys what are your thoughts
out there because these plays tend
dictate games it may not dictate in a
moment but eventually it's going to ca
someone a game um what's your thoughts
on that I just think uh me personally I
just think they should call it both ways
I think the things that the offensive
players get away with you know they
don't they don't call it you know a
subtle push when you run it down the
field that's a touchdown you know but if
we do anything we push them we we tug a
little bit they calling it you know we
never really get away with things so if
they called it both ways you know I
wouldn't have a problem but um I just
struggle with you know them getting away
with like push offs and stuff like that
so that's that's my my point on it yeah
and you know it's tough and we live in
we're living in a confined box where we
got to play safe we can't play dog
football where we can really play our
best football we got to be cautious
we're playing cautious football right
now and you know that tends to injury
that tends to giving up big plays and
things like that because of fearing that
you're going to cost your team um and
that's just the reality of it I think
things have to changeed things have to
be more challenged more reps more
something uh and more limits to these
rules because they're very one-sided and
I think that should change right away um
well let's look ahead to next week we'll
look ahead to next week in a little bit
but I want to talk about the first half
of the season um right now we're five
and three you know uh right now I would
say the biggest takeaway is that you
know we're a very good team but we have
small things to fix to be a great team
Gilly you've been on a Super Bowl team
you've been in these environments where
you went all the way you went all the
way twice yeah what does it look for us
or what does it take to get there that
you think we have to change to get there
you know what what do we have to do what
has to come on um so we can get to that
Super Bowl I think um you know this this
one of the most talented teams you know
I ever been on but I think with us just
me being on the team you know half of
the season so far it's just going to be
be able to win those tough games you
know when we play against you know good
teams just we're going to have to pull
it out at the end you know um we wasn't
able to do that you know whether it's
defensively offensively you can call it
whatever you want um but when it gets to
the end of the game we got to be able to
finish and know know those Super Bowl
teams and on those big teams that I
played on we finished you know whether
it was on defense you know offense going
driving the ball down scoring when they
had to defense making a big stop um
because that's what game's going to come
down to you know you're not going to
always have to be able to beat teams by
14 10 it's going to be back and forth
and um it's going to be the The Last Man
Standing yeah the Battle Zone I I agree
100% we got to find a way to win those
big games we got to find a way to Crunch
it out and finish them games so uh we
could be Victorious uh what is the
biggest adjustment moving forward I I
think just like what Gilly said find a
way to finish some big games and not
finding a way to not beat ourselves uh
limiting the penalties uh finding a way
to put us in better position better
leverage so we could come off blocks
finish at the ball better and uh get the
ball back to our offense because Dak
Prescott's playing at Elite level right
now I think that Dak Prescott should be
in the MVP conversation um if you
looking at numbers what he's able to do
uh his efficiency and things like that
Dak Prescott is playing at Elite level I
think he needs to be talked about more
uh not less and not in a downwards way
he is playing at Elite level um and we
should we should open our eyes open your
eyes people Dak presscott should be in
an MVP conversation um and I think he
will prove that leading out to the end
of this year um and winning some big
games and leading us to the playoffs uh
there was reports this week we yes we
signed uh Martavius Bryant um big
signing um what's your thoughts Gilly uh
Martavius Bryant um what he could bring
to our team how can he add value and so
forth uh I mean he's the first thing
that stick out with him you know is size
I think he like
6'4 um he he's got great speed I played
against him when he was in Pittsburgh
you know it was him
AB um someone uh James Washington it was
it was they had a lot of great receivers
you know he was making can play so I
think with that signing of him you know
he's going to come in you know he's
hungry he been in without ball for a
long time and I think he's hungry he's
going to help us out whenever that time
comes for sure I think what he brings to
the offense I think he does open up the
uh open up for CD I think you have to
respect him I think he's a nice Red Zone
threat with his size deep down the field
uh extend the field and things like that
and when he gets to learning the system
and he gets to um you know add value
especially with be Cooks uh this system
will really Thrive with speed and Talent
on our offensive side of the ball um so
I think this was a great signing um Lov
the what we seen but let's get into uh
more of you Gilly because you've been on
the show you're our star of the show so
you're Super Bowl Cham you're a
defensive play of the year one of six
quarterbacks to win the award and I talk
to you about this a lot and you know
this is why it's always great um to talk
to you about now and you going to share
your toolage and your knowledge out here
on the pod on the edge when did you know
your defensive player the your season
was different I just think um you don't
really know you just kind of just going
through the process you know week by
week you know I was covering the best
guy each week playing the manto man
coverage um my defense was playing Elite
you know I was picking stuff off taking
it to back to the house um just shutting
guys down you know I wouldn't let guys
catch many balls and I was covering the
best guy wherever he went wherever he's
in the slot you know
where it was a tight end you know
wherever at The X you know that's where
I went and I think um you know and I did
that all season and I was making Splash
plays our defense was like ranking
ranked number one in the league that
year and um you know you just kind of
just going through your normal routine
and towards the end of the season you
know my teammates was coming up to me
like bro you may win it and I'm like man
I may win it I I was just surprised just
cuz just cuz I I was just going through
my normal routine doing my thing but
next thing I know the season end you
know I go go to the esps you know wi
defensive play of the year you know that
was a big honor just cuz you know not
too many corners it's hard to win that
at the quarterback position you know
what I'm saying so and I was the only
player in in New England Patriot history
to win it um you know it was just a big
honor for my teammates you know um our
defense that year was
Elite and you know it just felt great
you know that's a big accomplishment you
know hopefully one day I still I play
this game because you know I want to be
in the hall one day and that's a goal of
mine so that that was one of the big
accomplish for me well you're definitely
going to the hall brother without a
doubt um Hall of Fame guy uh on and off
the field um you do terrific things I'm
so thankful you listened to me when I
told you I did the coast game to come to
Dallas cuz boy did we need you this year
uh you've been a great addition uh great
mentor for all of us um I want to know
in your opinion and I and I know this
answer um but everyone needs to know did
you do anything different or are you
always been structured or your routine
when you won defensive player the year
um have you always been like that or how
did you adapt or um learn how to learn
how to be a pro learn how to be a winner
one defense play the year I just think
uh when I went to New England you know
it was kind of different from me for
what I was used to um I was 5 years you
know in Buffalo we didn't lose we didn't
win no no games never been to the
playoffs and then I went to New England
you know and I think that culture there
was it was a little different but it
kind of made me um hungrier it uh it
challenged me more you know Bill being a
great coach you know he he he challenged
me each week you know he pushed me he
wasn't easy on me um and I think it it
elevated my game to another level and I
just think you know just being in that
that that at that team at that time you
know being around guys like Tom you know
Devin mccordi those guys being Pros you
know really teaching me you know how to
be a pro and really how to take care of
my body how to study film you know how
to prepare each week and I think that
that elevated my game a lot because I
was always a great player you know been
in in Buffalo all those years um but
when going to New England you know
playing in Prime Time games you know
playing in on on the big stage you know
going to Super Bowl so that that really
you know elevated my game a lot more
yeah and and this is a sidebar um and
and this is for the young athletes I
think um something big with me is we
want to find ways to connect to Young
athletes uh and things like that what
advice would you give to a young athlete
one who's striving to be a best corner
um striving to do great things make it
to the NFL and potentially make it to
the hall of fame one day what is a word
of advice to that 8-year-old or that 12y
old that 16y old that may look up to you
on Sundays or just may look up to you
and say man this is one of the best
corners ever um what what led to your
success I just think for me um just
growing up as a kid I was never
complacent you know um I could have a
great game and I always felt like I
didn't you know I can have a great year
and I always knew you know I had to do
it again the following year um and that
that that was from a young age from
middle school to high school you know
having a lot of scholarships but still
thinking I I didn't make it yet and um
you know and once I got to college you
know getting to the pros I'm just
getting started you know I still got to
keep proving myself you know I just
never you know getting complacent
staying even kill and learning you know
and I think one thing that as a as a kid
growing up is having that mentality and
you know every time you step on the
field to to be great you know because I
take the mindset nobody really cares
what you did last year two years ago 5
years ago you know it's about now so um
just taking that mindset each and every
year until you can't do it no more and
and and once that point hits you know
you don't have to worry about it but if
you have that mindset you always stay
hungry you always you always want to get
better and you'll stay getting better
each and every year yeah take take that
in um what I took from that is never
getting comfortable right um always
staying hungry uh never forget where you
came from and always learn how to become
a better version of yourself never
settle for that person you were the last
year um the year before that strive to
get that 1% or that 2% of you know self
scouting where can I can I get faster
can I change the direction better um
what can I do to stay ahead of the game
um because you don't never want to get
caught on that curve you want to stay
ahead of the curve so um we appreciate
that Gilly for sure but that that's
enough right for that let's get straight
into the NFL the the hottest te what's
going on I mean cuz it's spicy right now
y'all it's it's spicy let's look at the
playoff picture if the season ended
today for the AFC and NFC and what are
the matchups and predictions this is the
midseason midseason Awards right now
midseason what would it be right
now Chiefs with number one seed um to be
honest I H I have to take the
Ravens um I think Ravens go they beat
Bengals I think the Raven and and we're
going to get up we're going to get into
that matchup soon um we're gonna get
that Ravens Browns match up and to be
honest I don't know
if the Jags is the sleeper team right I
think the Jags is one of the better
teams in the league but but I don't know
if they want to see the
Browns um and and and it's strictly
because that D line with Miles Garrett
and everything is something serious I
think the Dolphins do beat the
Steelers um I
think and this is I I think I think
teams to honestly I think teams this
year in the NFL it's like no dominant
team I think anybody can get beat I
think if you don't bring your aame each
week I think you know whatever team
wanted that week is going to win you
know so um it's a little different than
this year than previous years to me I
just think a lot of teams the same you
know and I just think it's going to be
whoever wanted at the end yeah for sure
and I definitely think the Dolphins
could beat the Chiefs if they see each
other Inc Championship sure yeah yeah um
you know and and I think we we're going
to see Browns Ravens um this this week
so it it's going to be something serious
and we're we're going to get into that
in a second let's see the
NFC Cowboys
49ers uh I think Seahawks obviously uh
Seahawks obviously actually the Saints
been playing at a really high level and
I don't want to discredit that defense
have been I I think I'm GNA take New
Orleans um to to beat the Seahawks
I have to take the Lions the Lions been
playing I mean crazy I mean I think the
Lions been playing
crazy um and then obviously I I got to
bet on myself I have to I have to bet on
myself I'm I'm taking Cowboys over
49ers um and that leads to that that
match up that everyone wants to see
Eagles Cowboys uh I know yall excited
about that um and we're not going to get
too spicy cuz obviously we see them very
soon but yall know how I feel about that
always got better on yourself and
obviously I think the lions from this
view the Lions have a great chance of
going to the NFC Championship uh they
have a great chance I think they can
beat the Vikings and I also think
they're very capable beating the Saints
or the Seahawks in the divisional round
so it's very interesting these matchups
are super spicy I think this could be a
allaround great matchups for a lot of
teams I think it' be great playoff
football if this is how the season ended
right now one defense that really
impressed me this year and I've been on
them since week one um and not a lot of
people thought they would be as good
except for me and I'm taking full credit
for that because I understood who they
added and what they have on their team
how they drafted and their front and I
mean they're special and and that's the
Cleveland Browns the Browns are 4- one
when DeShaun Watson starts and one- two
when he doesn't and a lot of people were
questioning why they signed Deshawn
Watson well that's why they win games
when they have them and and let's not
get this and and we are very judgmental
about people's mistakes right and y'
know I'm high on uh Patrick Mahomes and
I'm high on J burrow but when they make
the same mistakes when they make wild
interceptions or throw it in the
coverage and I'm not saying Mahomes does
a lot but we don't give him the same
bashing as we do uh to guys like DeShawn
Watson Deshawn Watson at the end of the
day is a winner he's 4-1 he's he wins
when he starts he may make bad decisions
and every quarterback does no one's
perfect in National Football League it's
tough to win games but in the reality he
wins right and now you see them going
against the Ravens and I want to
Spotlight another player for the Ravens
who's really been stepping up he's our
interception leader and that's Gino
Stone you talking about guy that got
late or he might have been uh crazy uh
udfa I'm not sure but Gino he's a Iowa
guy I think he was a late guy he was he
was a fifth he's around a fifth sixth
round pick but he's leading the league
in with five interceptions I mean he's
hooping and regardless uh he's playing
extremely high level and this Ravens
defense is a I would say a top five
defense so the Browns have their hands
full offensively going against obviously
interception leader and uh they're going
against this highly rated Rams that this
they Blitz a lot they have a lot of
pieces that rotate in this scheme I mean
it it's truly special with the Ravens
have um Browns at the Ravens on Sunday
it's going to be a great game I'm super
excited to see it or get updates on it
um because I got a very important game
myself but this is a game y don't want
to miss I mean man uh what what's your
thoughts on ailly like Browns Raven
Sunday who are you taking Browns Ravens
I'll probably go with the Ravens I mean
I like Lamar I like deshan Watson too
but I think Lamar you know he's playing
great ball right now um they got a great
running game you know their receiver
Shifty their defense playing at a high
level and Coach Harbaugh you know he's
that he he don't play no gam so so I
think I think uh Baltimore get it um I
think it's going to be a great game but
I think Baltimore get it at the end yeah
yeah yeah for sure and the truth of the
matter is Lamar is playing at an MVP
caliber level there's a few quarterbacks
that's playing at an MVP caliber level
he's one of them and when that defense
is striking and he's striking at the
same time it's been very scary to see
the way they uh they they hit on the
lons no one thought that would happen I
mean they've been out of this war
recently it's going to be exciting match
up for both these teams
um I think the biggest thing is can that
Browns defense take over that game on
Sunday if they can take over the game
limit Lamar from doing what he does and
Miles Garrett takes that game over and
they got Denzel Ward slow down obj and J
flowers and they got Greg Nome uh Martin
Emerson and uh U at the Lineback if they
could find a way to slow down Lamar and
zidus Smith they got all this Talent
they can sign away to slow down Lamar I
think the Browns could take home that
win but they got a slow Lamar down from
this MVP caliber season he's putting
together cuz the Ravens is hot right now
the Ravens is looking like the team to
beat in the AFC they looking like the
most dangerous to weapons between Mark
Andrews Odell Beckham Z flowers uh they
still have baitman um the running back
Gus Edwards been playing at extremely
high level it has been a very exciting
to see the Ravens this year so let's see
and and actually let's pull up stats on
the yards allowed per defense
um and and this is this will really let
you know what's going on besides the
Cowboys the Browns the rav this is a
this is the top three this is the top
three defensive uh game with Ravens
right there and Browns right there and
that lets you know how important this
game was going to be if I'm a better man
I'm taking the under on the points I
think this is going to come down to a
defensive game I think it's going to be
a very good defensive game um and it's
going to be very exciting to see um so
let's not sleep on the let's not sleep
on the Baltimore Ravens or the Cleveland
Browns cuz this their defenses are
playing at extremely high level
interception leaders sack leaders you
name it they've been there so uh I mean
it's going to be it's going to be a good
game I I just feel like this the time of
the year where the great teams you know
take off you know this the time of the
year if where you see the teams that
really want it you know they start you
know start winning big games they start
you know dominating this this when you
really see the teams that's go really
you know be that them guys on the field
100% 100% um who are my top defenses
Midway uh point in the
season uh my my top five would be
obviously us uh Ravens Browns uh
Baltimore uh yeah uh I think the 49ers
and lions yeah I think those are the top
five
defenses up to date uh Midway through
this point so far this year um another
thing people been talking about is how
the Dolphins have not beat above 500
team this season what does that say
about Miami um honestly it says nothing
you know I don't I'm not a person that
likes to you know knick-knack on things
um the games they lost they were very
close games uh the Chiefs game um they
they didn't finish what the end the uh
eag game I thought it was a very
one-sided game um nothing really went
their way um and I think the Bills game
you know Josh Allen he played at
extremely high level if if that's how
I'mma lose um then I can grow from those
right I learn I can adjust to how to
play Josh Allen better um I can adjust
how to finish the game better against
the Chiefs I can adjust better uh how to
slow down the Eagles offense and not
give up so many penalties that led to
the game uh their their drives being
extended like you can learn from those I
we're not going to knickknack on the
Dolphins because I think they're still a
very good team uh I think people are
reaching usually when you're a very good
team and you know um you might hit a few
failures people like to pour down and
say oh you're not that good of a team
the Miami Dolphins is a very good and
talented team regardless right um jayen
Ramsey's got back the defense is playing
at very good right now um and their
offense is the most explosive offense
that we've seen the most speed that
we've seen in a very long time um
they're special regardless of how we may
look at it um they're a special team so
we shouldn't Overlook them um I think
they're a team that's going to give a
lot of teams trouble uh towards November
and December and uh obviously we play
them very soon um so I don't think we
should overlook them at all uh what what
what's your thoughts on uh
Miami I think um Miami is a great team I
think Miami am me um yeah they haven't
beat whatever they say top five team in
the league but I think they have the
talent to beat anybody you know they
have explosive players they have impact
players I think they're learning each
other just like everybody else is you
know and I think you know it's a long
season man it's it's it's a lot of
football left um and you can never count
nobody out I think Miami one of those
teams that's you know up and coming and
I think TS you know playing playing
starting to play good ball and and I
think they're going to have a good year
but I think I think they're a good team
I just think uh teams just you know they
got to have something to talk about them
not beating whoever whoever they play
the top three team but I think they got
the talent to beat anybody for sure yeah
100% And you know people were saying if
you know the Cowboys had similar CRI
criticism um if you were on the Dolphins
what would the response be I think it
would be the same response um at the end
of the day you you know football is a
unforgiving sport you know at the end of
the day you only get 17 games um out of
the year to prove what you got and if
you don't bring your best on that day
you can get beat and beat by anybody I
mean we've seen it and and that's just
the reality of it and you know um a lot
of people were throwing this saying you
know this is coming after uh obviously
um the Chiefs are a top five team they
keep um push themselves obviously they
EDG themselves in front of the Dolphins
in my top five uh at this point but
but um it's a it's very close at the end
of day and you know Patrick Mahomes said
the chief's defense was the best defense
in the NFL and the best defense that
he's had since he's been a chief and you
know for him that's a fair statement
that he can make
um you know he should have this
confidence in this type of uh Team you
know they got him crucial stops and a
lot of games uh where that it may not
happen and you as a quarterback you got
to lead your team in this way and it's
very important um but the Chiefs are
good defense they might not be the best
defense but he has that right to his
opinion uh no offense given but you see
um statistically you know who the top
five defenses are and you know it's just
simple like that but you know at the D
day they're winning games right uh what
they're seven- one right now uh or
seven- two um so you you can take that
away they're winning games they're
getting big stops uh when it matters so
they have one of the best defense
without a doubt um and you know and you
got to look at where he's coming from
this is a team that was never really
known for defense and they got these
pieces and they're putting together and
they're and they're going places uh
because their defense and offense and
how they've been going hand in hand
together um and that's always
important uh one of the biggest stories
last week was Josh jobs getting traded
to the Vikings and coming uh into the
game and getting the win over uh against
the Falcons um what you think and this
is my thing on Josh dobs uh he's a very
resilient player very overcoming and uh
obviously he loves the game you know
it's hard to learn a system and go out
there and compete there's a comes with a
lot of just knowing what the hell is
going on uh what's my assignment what
are the checks what are the and
sometimes it may even check me and Gilly
up sometimes because there's a lot to go
in the game so the fact that he was able
to do that uh in 36 hours it it's truly
amazing and inspiring um you know I I
think the league should take something
from Josh of being resilient being uh
persevering that it may not be your
first team it may not be your second
team you may get tossed around a lot in
this league but the day you have to find
your place and I think he's finding his
place that you know anywhere he goes we
know this is the guy that's going to
give us everything he got he's never
going to lead us wrong and and he's
going to put his all into us and his
teammates and you know I saw a little
something I think I was I saw his story
yeah online and it said the Cardinal
said they weren't trading them uh they
they weren't going to they were going to
start the rookie um and that just lets
you know how unforgiving this business
can be yeah you know this business it's
all about money attention and and never
about the person you know it's never
it's really going to be about the player
so the fact that he was able to push his
feelings to his side and never get
offended about his circumstances really
says a lot about Josh Do's the person so
Josh um keeping a hero and a
representation of the NFL because what
you're doing right now is truly amazing
and and it should be awarded uh because
I mean it is it that's not common it's
not Comm it's not common I mean he I
mean like he said I think he said his
coach told me he wasn't going to get
traded you know I've been traded before
so you know um it happens you know it's
a business at the end of the day um but
sometimes you got to take those things
and look at it look at it in a positive
way you know be able to rebound go to a
situation you know and play your best
ball you know nobody really cares about
you know what happened um before you
know you got traded you know you go to a
new team and he perform you know at the
end of the day it come down to per to
down to performance he was able to do
that and you know it's a great story
because he he didn't let it get under
his skin and he he made the best out of
his situation 100% um but you know there
is some bright side what's going on in
Arizona though back in Arizona Kyler
Murray's back um it's exciting to see
Kyler Murray back people who may have
know Kyler Murray is an exciting
football player exciting quarterback and
they said is this a real life side of a
football I think they
honestly they might have boosted that
football the football is not that big uh
they they did my man Kyler Ron there's
no way that's a real football uh but you
know uh and they're playing the Falcons
on Sunday uh what does this say if Kyler
doesn't
beat the Falcons but Josh dos this did
they make the wrong decision um
especially I think Josh dos is a great
backup I think Josh DS is a great backup
he's he's a great quarterback you know
kyum Murray haven't played you know in a
while so it's going to be his first game
back um but you know like I said before
he he got to find a way to get it done
you know he got to find a way and and
and the coaches and the GM they live
with that decision you know they they
traded away um dos and you know they
confident in kler Murray and and you
know he he got to get it done yeah and
and I and mind my words I don't want to
put Josh dobs in a a confined box saying
he's a great backup because obviously we
seen he's been playing a a backup role
amazingly but he's proven in this league
so far this year that he can potentially
be a great starter for sure um he he
he's putting together remarkable games
against us against the Falcons and he's
putting games together he might have a
chance to to be a great starter for a
team uh eventually especially if
injuries in the league keep happening um
we just never know how this might turn
out but Josh jobs is putting together an
incredible year but a guy that I've been
talking about almost every week and what
he de last week was just extremely
uncommon I mean this kid I mean i' said
this pre-draft that CJ stra was uh
qb1 I I mean people made fun of him
because his testing in the off season I
mean they made fun of him because they
said he didn't like to run but guess
what that stuff does not translate in
the NFL he's an in the pocket he'll sit
down make the big throw make the tough
throw he is looking what you will want
to see like he's be he doesn't even look
like he's a rookie no he look like he in
year five he coming to this rookie year
like he year five dominating he's coming
to take names he's coming to take
everything I mean there was an argument
to see if bejan or CJ was going to be
rookie I I don't even think it's a
debate I think CJ Str is going to be a
unanimous offensive rookie of the year I
mean it it won't even be close I mean CJ
set the single game rookie passing
yardage record with 470 yards and five
touchdowns and the the remarkable thing
is about CJ is the way he did it he led
his team to win the game with with 4
second seconds left 47 seconds left like
that's Elite that's Tom that's Tom Brady
yeah that's Tom that's what something
he'll do yeah I mean and it's easy
that's Tom we're talking about Tom Brady
level as a rookie quarterback I mean
this is a team that hasn't won what they
have they got this had the second
overall pick I mean I mean but this a
team I think he's won more games in the
last what two two maybe it might be
coming about I mean two three years and
this I mean he is going to he's changing
Houston he's changing Houston I think
now it's going to be players wanting to
go to Houston to play with him I think
he's going to be that type of
quarterback that type of Attraction
Houston has their forever quarterback
and that's great to see I mean this
couldn't have turned out any way any
better for Houston they Aus this draft
they did not mess this up and this is
huge CJ stoud he's a top 10 quarterback
in NFL right now and I don't even think
it's debatable and if you really want it
debatable he is having an MVP season if
he continues it I think CJ St might be
one of the one of very few I don't know
the record on this very few to win an
MVP and offensive rookie of the year uh
award he's playing at that level that'll
be crazy that'll be crazy and that's the
reality he's playing at that level and I
mean I think I just love that drive at
the end of the game bro that that that
showed me you have ice that that showed
me you have every like and he said it he
said you give me you give me however
much time I'm going I'm going to get it
done and this is the second time he's
done that I
mean he uh I mean oh we just got the
stats Jim Brown is the only other person
with MVP and offensive rookie of the
year so he has a chance up join Hall of
Fame company Hall of Fame company I mean
this is absolutely remarkable CJ my
brother you know we actually family tied
CJ keep going brother I'm so glad you
prove the haters wrong I love it this
story is legendary uh you're trafic
human being you're showing them you're a
terrific uh football player my brother
keep going you are one of a kind special
player I'm glad to see your success um
and and so forth but Le let let's move
on to another rookie I have high hopes
for he may not be offensive rookie of
the year because his usage for the
Falcons and people are wondering why
he's not getting used in the redone and
and let me say this right
now the FAL have drafted Drake London
bejon Robertson and KY
Pitts and I think this might be some of
the worst usage
of athletes that you could draft for
your offense and I mean the history of
all drafting I mean this is just bad
yeah I mean Kyle Pitts maybe has three
four touchdowns in his career I mean
regards to the the injury yeah um Drake
London he he's being okay he's battle
injuries but he hasn't really been used
very much and you have a a saquan
Barkley Barry Sanders type back
and you have this type of athlete and
you don't find him the way to get in the
ball I listen I don't care what beon
opens up away from the
ball my mindset is my best players have
to touch the ball it's tough because I
mean Kyle pittz I played against him he
Elite um Robinson you know he's a great
back and the receivers he's a he's a
great receiver it's just it's
something's going on I don't know what's
going it has to be frustrating like why
draft him that and especially at seventh
pick why draft him that early if you're
not going to use him I mean this is a
guy that could change your offense like
I I just don't get it this is he's so d
Dynamic this is
so this is so he's so Dynamic it it's
mindboggling it's mindboggling to
witness this what's going on bejan tell
him to let you loose let you loose
another injury that we just seen uh
recently and and that's Daniel Jones I
mean we're playing the Giants uh this
weekend uh you hate to see it Danel
Jones is out with the ACL uh praise up
to Daniel Jones this is a guy I've been
rooting for even though he's a division
uh I always hope for the best for all
athletes in the NFL but uh you know it
it it sucks tough man it's tough cuz you
know he's a Charlotte guy he's from the
Carolinas you know he's uh fighting to
get back he just came back I think he
was the first game back right yeah and
then go down on like a nonc contact
injury you know that's that's tough man
and you know you never want to see your
guys go down like that and you know
prayers are for him for sure hopefully
he come back strong and and be a good
player for sure um man praise up for uh
you DJ um obviously we hate to see that
uh you're a great athlete um obviously
you gain your best wishes from me and
Gilly uh recover soon um and see you
next year we're taking some questions
from the chat some some questions from
the chat before we wrap this up um they
said y'all have been talking a lot about
MVP who are y'all mid-season MVP
candidates uh as of right now my top
five would be offense yeah this
obviously it's offensive it's obvious
it's offensive yeah um I think my top
five would
be uh Lamar
Jackson uh Dak Prescott CJ stoud Tua and
um Tua and I think Tyreek Hill for sure
and Tyreek Hill Tyreek Hill those are my
top five MVP candidates um I can go with
those uh who
else Herz can't put Herz in there we
could put Herz in there yeah he playing
the leag ball too yeah I think it's
arguable uh yeah between him and CJ yeah
um but and and I might be biased CJ's my
guy yeah but I think Herz and CJ is
playing great football right now yeah
they playing great football he doesn't
have all Pros he doesn't have Pro bow I
mean he does have lar tanzu but what
he's doing with less around him who you
saying who who is that uh CJ Stout oh
yeah yeah for sure what he also I mean
they have great players good players
over there but he's when you a great
player you make other players around you
and he's making them great yeah he's
making them great tank Dell is looking
Nico Collins is looking great tank
Noah Brown just went for 163 yard I mean
he's making and these aren't bad players
he's making them look great so that's
that that's something that y'all can say
that it's arguable but those are uh my
top five we're not taking those away and
that's a tough top five that's that's
myp I mean if you take Tyreek Hill out I
mean jayen Herz is right there for sure
but I mean Tyreek Hill I mean 1,000
yards in 7 eight gam crazy he may go for
two he may go for he may go for 2,000
No No Cap you make for 2000
um it said Mich you're the best what's
your guys take on Don Bland and Maris
Bell um you know I think my take is
these are two guys that came in ready to
work hungry and want to get on the field
and not taking no for an answer they're
they're
going berserk I mean Bell has stepped up
in a tremendous way and he's trending
upward he's only going to continue to
get better he's only been playing
linebacker for what eight games yeah so
I mean this is something remarkable I'm
loving to see um these two guys that
work hard and they want to get better
yeah for sure I think um Bell you know
he's been playing great ball he stepped
up in a big way you know to help our
defense you know playing linebacker
flying to the ball and uh making plays
for us and I think Don Bland you know
one thing that stick out with me to to
to him he's uh you know he's only in
year two man and he act like he in year
six you know he's so even kill you know
he comes to work every day you know
hungry he he want to get better you know
he's competing in practice every day you
know he doing all the right things you
know you you would not think he's he's
laidback um and I think he's going to
have a great career you know just based
off the way he works the r carrying
himself and um I'm just happy you know I
can I can share the field with him you
know teach him as much as I can and uh
you know him keep making plays yep I I
agree 100% Gilly do you think bilich
really deserves to be on the on the hot
seat I think um you know that's just the
world we live in you know the National
Football League you know when you're
losing you know changes have to be made
um but I think Bill is a legendary coach
you know I wouldn't be the player I am
today without bill you know he taught me
a lot in my career you know how to be a
pro you know his preparation during the
week you know and he he you you know
Hall of Fame Coach man and and you know
it's when you're not getting a job done
you know they always you know it's
always question marks and um but I think
that's a craft question you know he he
going to make the best decision for his
organization um but I think you know
Bill's hands downs one of the best
coaches I ever had yeah amen yeah um
what do you think of pen State chances
now that hard Baugh is banned from the
sidelines first of all I believe our
chances was always through the roof it's
always is we are Penn State uh I expect
us to get this Victory I expect us to go
on top and beat them in the uh I and in
State College Pennsylvania just like we
did when I was there it may not be a wi
out but our fans is going to show up and
show out like how they do every time and
let's just see if they can control that
Penn State environment and I know they
can so it's always we are baby I know
what it is uh they say you got to
replace that Gillies Coast Jersey with a
Cowboys number 21 ASAP while he's there
and actually we are not even replacing
that we are getting the original we're
getting that New England Jersey the New
England Jersey yeah I'm I'm going to get
him that patch Jersey you know that that
vintage patch Jersey and um you know get
him right but I told him he got to take
that that other Jersey down you know
over there to the to the I think it's
our left yeah we got to take AJ Brown
down he said AJ Brown got to come down I
said if we get the Vintage one he'll
come down um but before we wrap let's
give a little preview to next week
obviously a division opponent Giants
loaded with saquon Barkley speed with
guys like Jaylen Hyatt uh a rookie
quarterback coming in the place but
these guys are still have a lot of
potential they're still very talented
team um and they're trying to obviously
save their season Brian the ball grhe
head coach uh we just need to prepare
not Overlook these guys I mean these
guys is going to come they're going to
give us their best shot um defensive
front Kayon Tibido is playing great uh
Dex Lawrence is playing great and we got
a handsful so Cowboys Nation y know
stand up come down to AT&T Sunday 3:00
we need you we got to take over we got
to k kick all Giants fans out of the
stadium and make it real simple hey we
going to open the gates for y'all and we
going to lock the gates just that's like
that's like our slogan open the gates
and we going to lock the gates and we
ain't going to let nobody leave that
Survivor and let's get straight to it
Cowboys Nation uh we always appreciate
y'all anything y'all want to say uh to
to to uh anything you want to say to
Cowboys Nation n Cowboys Nation man it's
going to be a great game this week you
know be loud you know we we still hungry
you know it didn't end how we wanted to
last week hey but it's a new week you
know we got a a division opponent coming
in man just stick with us you know we
grinding we working hard every day you
know we go get it done hey we appreciate
y'all thank you for tuning in to the Eds
with your boy Michael Parsons and thank
you
for coming in coming on to the show we
extremely appreciate that um and we'll
see y'all next week next Monday on the
edge love and appreciate y'all always
[Music]
y